a lot of us grew up to have a
romanticized view of federal prosecutors
and law enforcement they were all like
Eliot Ness and The Untouchables truth
justice and the American Way
it was about locking up the bad guys and
protecting the rest of us and there are
many dedicated men and women across the
country serving as assistant US
attorneys who are doing just that but
sadly we've also seen egregious examples
in recent years of prosecutions of
prominent figures that seem to have been
politically motivated prosecutions that
resulted in huge miscarriages of justice
one such case was that of conservative
filmmaker author an old college friend
Dinesh D'Souza who was pardoned today by
President Trump for a conviction
stemming from a twenty thousand dollar
bundled campaign contribution to 2012
Senate campaign of friend Wendy long
Obama's US Attorney Preet Bharara went
for broke against a Souza in a case that
could have been easily disposed of with
a fine and should have been this is de
Souza whom I spoke with exclusively on
radio today with regard to Preet Bharara
you know I see him as along with Eric
Holder as sort of part of this Obama
team of goons if you will that was
unleashed to get me in retaliation for
the movie I made about Obama and I think
Ferrara's ambition was that this would
he would prove that by getting a fellow
Indian he would kind of endear himself
to the Obama team it was a move of
ambition as I understand it but you know
this this would have to file this into
the Karma is a department we Ferrara got
fired by by Trump and I got pardon well
D'Souza was sentenced to eight months at
a community confinement center in five
years of probation and community service
a thirty thousand dollar fine and
counseling he called it a failed attempt
at re-education when Republican members
of Congress who suspected political
motivations pushed for the release of
D'Souza's FBI file the department bought
when they finally turned over the file
least made access to the file they found
out
his political affiliation and were
critical of Obama had indeed been
referenced from the FBI reports seen by
a Republican member of Congress it said
the following D'Souza is likely an ultra
conservative right-wing author and
creator of a documentary critical of the
Obama administration because of
D'Souza's purported conservative beliefs
it is likely that D'Souza orchestrated
the excess contributions the agents name
who wrote the above description was
redacted the expenditure then authorized
for a case concerning $20,000 with the
campaign contributions $100,000 what my
case shows in miniature is the way that
Obama and Hillary to have gangster eyes
the US politics there's a new term
that's come in American politics and
then and Trump is I think very well
aware of it in some ways he's the
product of it it's not just D'Souza who
the former Obama Justice Department
targeted remember what happened to
Virginia's Republican Governor Bob
McDonnell who many thought could have
been a future presidential candidate he
was prosecuted on corruption charges by
US Attorney Dana buente who was
appointed by the Obama administration
mcDonald's conviction was eventually
overturned by a unanimous Supreme Court
it's worth noting that Brent a was also
colleagues with Jim Comey and has been
interviewed by the special counsel Bob
Muller on what call me relayed to him
about his meeting with Trump Bente is
now serving as the general counsel of
the FBI and then there's former Democrat
governor from Illinois rod Blagojevich
who was sentenced to 14 years in prison
on federal bribery charges despite the
fact that he never took a bribe the
prosecutor in the case
another Jim Comey friend Patrick
Fitzgerald bla goes wife patty recently
appeared here on the angle no 10 years
ago these same people call me Fitzgerald
Mueller used these out-of-control
prosecutors and FBI agents came after my
husband
they're unchecked power to undo an
election by the people and these are
politically motivated opportunists who
use their offices for their own personal
enrichment to further their careers and
remember the decision to investigate the
leaking of CIA agent Valerie Plame's
name in 2003 Bush White House official
Scooter Libby was convicted in that case
not for leaking but for lying to
investigators Trump recently pardoned
him something George W Bush should have
done long before leaving office do you
remember who decided to appoint the
special counsel and the plain Libby case
then Deputy Attorney General Jim Comey
whom did call me choose a special
counsel his old chum Patrick Fitzgerald
it's also incestuous now Fitzgerald is a
wealthy partner at my old law firm
Skadden Arps and is representing whom
Jim Comey in his dealings with Special
Counsel Bob Muller that brings us to
today or many of these same figures who
have been celebrated by media elites are
back at work using their position and
their pedigree and an ongoing effort to
purge the country of President Donald J
Trump
what started as concerns about Russian
collusion has now morphed into an
ever-changing obstruction of justice
narrative all because Trump fired
someone whom he was constitutionally
permitted to fire for any reason in
federal investigations the government
has limitless budgets subpoena power and
an army of prosecutors on its side let's
not forget so targets should not be
chosen or eliminated on the basis of
their political views nor because
they're considered big fish whose
prosecutions could pay big time and big
career dividends down the road this is
neither just nor enforcement of the law
what it is is it's big-game hunting with
a political preference and that's the
angle